so obviously there's lots to
congratulate you on but before we get to
the music
i want to congratulate you on getting
through hot wings
with i mean
it's really hard given your you know
all of your accomplishments like where
does that rank um
probably number two in the top two
and that's not a euphemism for what
happened afterwards after hot one
oh my god the next day was painful some
of my team tried
some of the spicy sauce as well and it
was a lot
i love it i love it um so yes
congratulations on the music
you know to me you sound so confident
on this album is it safe to say this is
you and your most confident musically
oh yeah completely yeah completely i
feel
um i'm not scared i'm just like
excited to sing and make things and i
was in the most creative space of my
life when i was writing this album
so it was really wonderful to do and i
met so many incredible people
and broke with so many amazing artists
what helps you get into into that space
is that sort of fun well i think it's
i think i think what helps me get into
that space
is um living life you know i love to
to when i'm writing i want to be going
out and meeting people and enjoying
myself and
and that's definitely what helped me
this time i i was
dancing lots and i'm glad i got it all
in before this year
oh absolutely yeah yeah um
when was the moment you know that you
found
you were most confident in just saying i
love who i am
um i think probably when i
started to tackle my body issues against
a year a few years ago now
and there was just one summer that i
just got so fed up with
and not being able to take my top off
around the pool and
not being able to do certain things and
i
for about four months i really tackled
hard against that and
it just really set me free and it set me
free in every sense
yeah the um you know given the themes of
love
and loss and longing that your music
helps people
uh go through what are your thoughts on
love
now how have they changed over the few
years
oh my gosh so much i feel like i'm just
getting older i guess um
i'm i'm i'm not interested in that kind
of um
the hedonistic uh uber romantic love
where it's
um you know i think i i love that whole
uh the whole concept of you know
going so hard with someone and both of
you
you know falling into this mess with
each other and living
off of someone almost and then i think
now i'm just looking for a
friendship and companionship and
kindness
i think do you think it's a mistake for
people to say
oh these are particular qualities i'm
looking for in someone to spend time
with
um sometimes yeah because i don't think
you know what you want until it
it comes to you um but i think certain
qualities like kindness
uh a calmness
someone who can you know control their
anger and their
emotions things like that that's that's
good to to want that and to not want the
yeah i want to talk a bit about your
dancing because in a few of the videos
you know i i love it when people are
dancing in their videos and in diamonds
like it's just you what's the story
there are you freestyling or is that
choreography that was set no
i did i did choreo for that and we we
worked on it for
a week before and it was so much fun
so much fun is that is that how you
would move when you're out like you said
you know you got all this dancing out
before everything got locked down is
that the way that you would move when
you're out with your friends
probably not structured probably a
little bit i'd be drunker normally so be
a bit more messy
and you know we talked a little bit in
the beginning about your accomplishments
but you know you
you have had so many um at this stage
when you're releasing an album are you
thinking about
sort of keeping up with those things
what is that
what is the successful album to you no
i'm not um a successful album to me is
now something that i am proud of and
something i enjoy
um i mean the hardest part of releasing
a record right now
though is that i'm not getting to see
fans and
and meet people and actually uh
feel things you know a lot of it's
happening from behind a screen
or a laptop screen and it's that that's
that's difficult
um but yeah for me it's less and less
about
sales and stats and more about
expression and
uh honesty yeah
do you see you know the way things have
gone this year
for you know creative people for people
that are creating things music movies
do you see that having an impact on the
stories that people are going to be
telling
in the near future the way even music is
going to be
received yeah of course massively yeah i
think
um this stillness and uh this time
has shifted everyone and um there's a
lot of pain out there and i don't know
if people are ready to talk about it
quite yet but
i think they will be looking back on it
as a time of hardship
yeah um you spoke uh about
the idea of being perfect and sort of
countering the idea that you had when
you were younger
of what perfection was do you have
though an idea
for you personally of what perfection is
yeah or for me it was happiness to
always be happy and to not feel sad
to never have mental health issues
to um constantly be in control to never
be nervous
um all those things but i've had to
accept that that's all
they're always going to be there and
i've got to become friends with them
um for me to come to more of a peaceful
place
and i've also learned that you know
happiness is an emotion that comes and
goes
so you've got to let it let it come and
then let it go
as far as perfection when it comes to
music is there
a perfect time frame between albums like
is that a plan
thing or does it just happen when the
music happens
it just happens when the music happens
it really does i mean
um i'm learning more and more as well
the quicker the better because
um i hate sitting on songs it's it's
it's hard to sit on songs for a long
time
yeah when um when do you think that
you're going to
you know you've talked about the idea of
having his family
and also of having that garden center
and
you know everyone has their faces in
life right and i think as we all get
older we think about
what's what's the next 10 years going to
look like for you do you think that's a
10-year thing do you think that's a
15-year thing 20-year thing
i think i'm 28 now so i think the first
step is get a dog
and then um and then after that
start to introduce things but i i'd love
i'd love to
if i was to have kids i'd i'd have kids
before 35 i think
that's what i'd love to do yeah and do
you think that if they were
um musically inclined do you think that
you would
put all of your weight behind that 100
oh no i wouldn't want them to be in
music i mean if they wanted to they
could but
i'd be like don't do it really why not
i i'd say certainly do not be famous
i'd i'd be saying if you want to
do music do it for the passion of it and
stick with that
but um don't do it to be famous i'd say
you